has anybody ever like farted while you
like doing this yes yes I don't know it
like
rest down to your comfort level some
people like to keep their underwear on
or a bra it's it's not going to affect
your massage like kind of creepy in that
little holster I just use a real basic
biodome cream oil is also better on
people they're very hairy so if you ever
had to deal with like anybody's gross
skin I did have one client will just
shed a lot of skin it's you and that
situation you just kind of roll through
it you know you gotta exfoliate once in
a while
guys are uh you know top of owner guys
do sometimes get an erection on the
table I mean it's not even really a
sexual arousal sometimes sometimes some
guys get real embarrassed about it just
go back to sleep ignore it you get away
with not massaging them you never know
when the person's gonna wake up and I
just feel like if you got busted doing
that feel like getting caught stealing
or get tired of listening to like the
same like flute music yes people
definitely grown or snore when they fall
asleep if I have someone else waiting
outside or whatever and you hear someone
in the room oh I know they're thinking
what's going on in there so what is a
not a not is a bundle of muscle fibers
that have stuck together
we're massage therapists massage
therapists for people that have gone to
school that have a license a masseuse
would be an unlicensed female not always
but generally associated with the sex
trade no one has asked me for a happy
ending directly to my face I've had the
client on the table go aren't you hot
they're trying to say you should take
your shirt off I'm saying maybe you
should go to sleep it gets tiresome
defending of the profession I take a lot
of care in making whoever is on my table
feel 100 percent safe and comfortable
do I took you based on how long you you
massage or it's a good tip if you go to
a spa or somewhere where not all the
money is going to them then I would say
yeah tip your massage therapist you have
someone like me I'm comfortable making
what we've agreed to to think that you
can succeed out here without something
to release that stress that tension to
keep yourself healthy if we're up to me
let's say massage is the best way